yeah we returned to Oz this time with no
deadly desert no wheelers no freak a
scary woman who pulls her head off and
changes her head out with another head
you guys ever seen The Return to Oz when
you were kids no well I did and it
freaked his out of me today this is
more pleasant oz the great and powerful
so I was the great and powerful is the
story of Oz the great and powerful that
is the wizard of oz before he was really
the wizard of oz although he wasn't ever
really wizard he was a dude and they
play on that fact in this movie Oz is
played by James Franco he's a trickster
he's a conman he's an illusionist he's
in Kansas doing his shows and as he said
in The Wizard of Oz he was in a balloon
tornado swept him away now he's in Oz
the Land of Oz as we kind to remember it
really mostly not because they have new
technology now so it's going to look
different and therefore that you have
wicked witches and you have good witches
and you have oz who needs to save the
world or at least the Land of Oz which
is probably in his subconscious this
really dangerous taking on something
like the Land of Oz the Wizard of Oz is
such a classic so now we're gonna return
there without that feeling of something
being classic it's gonna be nude we're
not gonna have a nostalgia wrapping us
into it it doesn't mean there's not a
lot to like in this movie oz the great
and powerful does a good job at making
it its own adventure not relying on The
Wizard of Oz but having some things you
know sometimes or at least references
were there like I had still Oz and
you're kind of like oh is this you know
original Wizard of Oz going on
still no deadly desert or wheelers who
have faces on their heads who crumble in
the deadly desert and scar you as a
child I was the great and powerful
really is a good story about Redemption
you know that story of a guy who's
really not the best he can be but he
makes his way he's a con man for God's
sakes he's not the most altruistic human
being however they're like you're the
wizard we need but maybe not the one we
deserve right now Oh so Oz is like wait
do I become really rich with a treasure
if I'm your wizard yes okay yeah I'm
your wizard we already knew in The
Wizard of Oz he's not a wizard he's the
guy behind the curtain you know he's
just uses smoke and mirrors and
illusions and in this movie like in The
Wizard of Oz to crew that he meets a
really representations of people he knew
in the world like in Kansas in the real
world
Zach Braff plays the flying monkey and
Zach Braff which is ultimately the same
character he was a little monkey guy who
would do whatever he said because he's
his magic assistant one of the best
parts of this movie in the part when I
really knew this movie actually had
heart it's a little porcelain doll girl
there
like three times in the movie where I
teared up a bit all of which had to do
with this little porcelain dollar girl
it's just a really cool parallel of what
he gets to do in Oz and her little
problem and what he couldn't do in the
real world I'm telling you that was good
and for nothing else in the movie
if you hate the movie you can't deny
that we like movies suck that was good
dog you know teared up a bit if you
didn't please put the matches down stop
burning boxes of kittens for the love of
God and I like how they had a throwback
to the old Wizard of Oz in the sense
that you know the old Wizard of Oz when
Dorothy using Kansas doll black and
white and she gets to Oz in its color
and this one kind of the same trick it's
four by three aspect ratio which is you
know this aspect ratio and it's black
and white it looks plain then he gets to
Oz and then oh it's wide screens in
color and yeah the Wicked Witch is in
this movie and I do like how she has
character The Wizard of Oz is like oh
yeah she's the bad person and she does
bad things and Oz but in this movie she
does have more character I like that
doing a prequel a lot to opportunity to
show more about the villains in the
later movie the movies not perfect
though it does have problems there are
some pacing issues where you're like
alright well we're doing this for the
sake of doing this there are a couple
scenes where I was like that just
happened just to show that Oz is just
kind of a creepy place sometimes didn't
add anything to the plot didn't take
away anything from the plot those didn't
need to be in it also some of the CGI I
get it Oz is a magical land it's going
to have a lot of CGI but try to avatar
that try to make the CGI look
really real at least because sometimes
it looked kind of like a cartoon I feel
like it's a cheap excuse to be like yeah
you know it's meant for kids they're
supposed to look like cartoons not a
good excuse for me you know just don't
make it look like a cartoon it's a movie
for kids
oh and family so make it look like a
movie for kids and families not a
cartoon for kids and families if it's
not supposed to be a cartoon in the end
I actually enjoyed the out of Oz
the great and powerful a lot more than I
thought I would one of the biggest
things that suffers from is the fact
that it's not a classic like the movie
it's springboarding off of it's a movie
about Oz and we grew up with the Wizard
of Oz so we're really nostalgic Lee
attached to the Wizard of Oz it doesn't
feel like The Wizard of Oz because it's
not the Wizard of Oz and I can't take a
checkpoint off of a movie because it's
not as nostalgic as its predecessor or
sequel in the sense that this is a
prequel I like James Franco as Oz I like
the characters I like the witches I like
the point of the movie a guy who steps
up to be better than he thought he could
that's really cool families will have a
good time with it
I enjoyed the out of it I will say
Oz to
and powerful I would actually buy on
blu-ray I was going to say it's really
really really really really strong to
alcohol required but at that point it's
called I'd buy it on blu-ray so I was
the great and powerful have you seen it
do you like The Wizard of Oz and what do
you think of Return to Oz their lives is
the only time I can actually ask you
this question Return to Oz that's a real
movie it happened and I saw it have you
seen it whatever you think about all
those questions that I just asked that I
can't remember comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more